buenos días seguramente esta atención
que hemos visto entre francia y el reino
unido- creciente no solamente ahora por
la pesca un asunto fundamental para los
dos lados del canal de la mancha puede
seguir subiendo de tono porque lo cierto
es que las dos partes han expuesto sus
argumentos y ninguna al momento quiere
ceder el reino unido- sobre este
episodio reciente de los barcos ha dicho
que está investigando la actuación de
las autoridades francesas sobre todo por
las amenazas de las últimas horas un
vocero de downing street- que es el
gobierno la residencia del gobierno
británico ha dicho que como lo
mencionaba estas amenazas son
desproporcionadas y no lo que se espera
de un socio y un amigo tan cercano
también ha dicho que estas posibles
amenazas son violación del derecho
internacional y si se dan entonces el
reino unido- responderá ha dicho además
que este país ha cedido en un 98 por
ciento de las pretensiones pretensiones
francesas sobre la pesca lo cierto es
que se espera que el presidente francés
y por el johnson se vean la próxima
semana en glasgow para asistir a la
cumbre pero no hay certeza que entonces
esas asperezas puedan animarse tan
rápidamente